was haben sie uns denn heute als these
mitgebracht und ich würde sagen sie
haben vor allem eine besorgnis
mitgebracht an diesem tisch absolut und
wir reden über energieversorgung
jährigen über autarkie und wir vergessen
total dass wir das wichtigste gut was
wir hier in deutschland produzieren
nämlich die wichtige energiequelle die
wir täglich zu uns nehmen die nahrung
die setzen wir gerade dramatisch aus
spiel und das ganze jetzt nicht aufgrund
der aktuellen regierung sondern auf der
fonds aufgrund der vorgänger regierungen
seit mindestens zehn jahren ist es so
dass wir mit verordnungen drangsaliert
werden uns wehren fußfesseln ja sogar
handfesseln angelegt und wir sollen
trotzdem noch dasselbe leisten was
physisch praktisch nicht möglich ist und
solange wir uns davon nicht lösen und
wir haben nun mal auch aufgrund der
ukraine krieges aber auch vorher schon
einen absoluten mangel an ernährung
natürlich gibt es ein verteilungsproblem
aber grundsätzlich hungern die menschen
direkt bei uns vor der haustür in
nordafrika in den maghreb-staaten es
fehlen weizen mengen die kommen aus der
schwarzmeerregion übrigens nicht raus
und die ersten schiffe die ausgelaufen
sind die sind nämlich nicht nach afrika
gefahren sondern sind auch europa
gefahren nach irland frankreich und
großbritannien also so viel zu der
doppelmoral von der wir darüber
gesprochen haben und wenn wir so weiter
machen sind wir nicht mehr in der lage
dass wir uns tatsächlich hier selbst
ernähren können das ist jetzt schon
faktisch wobei obst und gemüse haben den
selbstversorgungsgrad von weit unter 30
prozent das würde mir keiner hören wenn
sie mit politik mit der aktuellen auch
reden da wird mit zahlen notiert die
sind über zwei jahre alt die sind
überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell und damit
wird immer gerecht werde oder da kommt
die rechtfertigung dass wir doch autark
sind sind wir in keinem bereich mehr
wenn wir noch mal ganz konkret hinblick
wie und ich möchte wirklich dass dass
sie diese besorgnis auch teile wie geht
es den bauern dreckig die wir haben ein
höfesterben und einen landwirtschafts
sterben wir reden hier von familien wir
reden von familien die seit generationen
das machen was für frieden und wohlstand
seit hunderten von jahren geld und jeden
tag sterben dutzende betriebe selbst
milchviehbetriebe und wir haben übrigens
ein mangel gerade an milch wie sechs
milchviehbetriebe machen jeden tag die
bude zu und es muss uns klar sein anders
als bei kohlekraftwerken die wir jetzt
ja verzweifelt versuchen wieder ans netz
zu bringen macht einen
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb zu macht er
nie wieder auf und dann stehen wir
irgendwann darum die sehen ja natürlich
das wetter verändert sich total wie es
das bei uns auch und das ist in anderen
weltteilen genau so wollen wir uns
wirklich in der abhängigkeit begeben von
irgendwelchen diktatoren von herrschern
wie hellboy szenario der übrigens im
letzten monat mehr regenwald abgeholzt
als jemals zuvor warum denn wohl damit
er stellt sich schon auf ein dass er
irgendwann ein springen und uns unseren
job ja faktisch wegnimmt das macht die
politik um uns dann zu ersetzen ihn geht
es wie geht es ihrem ruf speziell also
haben sie auch angst dass ihnen das aus
droht also wir haben schon vor jahren
mit 23 standbein aufgestellt wir haben
noch mal ein hotel wir haben biergarten
wir backen seinen kuchen also wir kommen
halbwegs klar weil sie können von der
landwirtschaft heute nicht mehr länger
wir können unseren hof wir haben ein
ziemlich großen hoffen dass der ist
komplett formel schutz denkmalschutz der
kostet viel geld und den zu unterhalten
ist mit der landwirtschaft so nicht
möglich auf gar nichts mit dem nachwuchs
in der landwirtschaft ja das ist ja auch
ein ding wir haben ja kein
fachkräftemangel ich glaube wir sind die
einzigen industriezweig wir sind
übrigens auch der größte arbeitgeber mit
dem nachgelagerten bereich während
landwirtschaft sind nicht der bauer
sucht frau von rtl das ist ja oft
verkannt er ist ja leider so sondern wir
haben überhaupt keinen nachwuchsmangel
wir haben die best ausgesetzt da die
branche die ich kenne ja ist da ist
wirklich so wie bei ihrem wahlkreis gibt
es tatsächlich fachkräftemangel auch bei
den bauern na also das land schon als
landwirt auch genau
75 im bereich pflanzenzucht eher weniger
aber viehzucht da ist das problem der
handfessel lösen und da läuft es in
sketchen der analyse noch ein
schrittchen weiter wir haben gerade über
politik geschimpft jetzt wirklich mal
nicht über politik auch wenn ich
manchmal den eindruck habe dass
landwirtschaft mittlerweile auch unter
dem einfluss von eu zu einer
planwirtschaftlichen veranstaltung wird
ja jetzt kämpfe ich mal auf das volk auf
die bürger ja sie wollen sich weiter
alle zum feind machen herr kreispolizei
bürger gleich noch mit
der deutsche verbraucher wenig dass man
so pauschal sagen darf der deutschen
verbraucher er will immer das billigste
dass das kommt ihr euch natürlich in
form von dumpingpreisen anja der
deutsche verbraucher will nicht das was
jahreszeitlich bei uns wächst und
geerntet wird sondern er will halt im
winter dann frisches obst aus südamerika
früchte aus
gemüse aus südafrika und so weiter und
so weiter da wäre wirklich mal ein
umdenken notwendig jetzt kommt aber ihre
genannten republik die sie ins spiel
gebracht haben
also die bürger hier ist der bürger ja
ich möchte noch ganz ganz kurz bevor ich
mich noch ganz kurz eine aussage von
ihnen zeigen hier lieber sie sind uns ja
aufgefallen wir möchten ja nächsten
monaten hier viel öfter bürger am tisch
sitzen haben und ich möchte dass einmal
ganz kurz noch zeigen
jetzt haben wir gewissheit wir wissen
also jetzt dass wir nicht nur bei der
bundeswehr und energie bei unserer
gesamten infrastruktur komplett lang
sind so dass wir auch jetzt beim
wichtigsten überhaupt nämlich bei unser
selbstversorgung mit ernährung auch
komplett im arsch wie soll ich sonst
erklären dass ich ein weizen gedroschen
habe auf einen absoluten spitzen
standort mit einem protein gehalt von 8
8 prozent fallen sie sich wissen damit
kannst du kein brot backen unmöglich
selbst der beste bäcker da draußen kann
das nicht und wie kommen wir zu diesen
werten wie kommen wir dazu dass aus
allen himmelsrichtungen deutschland
gerade die gleiche scheiße gemeldet ich
habe eine ganz konkrete frage was was
würde ihre arbeit erleichtern weil sie
sagen ihnen sind hände und füße
gefesselt könnten sie mir konkret sagen
was das ist wir bleiben noch einmal beim
protein kann ich bald darauf baut auch
hier die frage dann die frage wir haben
deutschland hat 2012 nach brüssel die
messwerte unser brunnen gemeldet also
unseres grundwassers und deutschland war
das einzige land was nicht wie alle
anderen länder den durchschnitt gemeldet
hat sondern wir haben nur die höchst
fertig meldet auf und aufgrund dessen
fußen bei uns drei düngeverordnung das
heißt wir müssen und müssen immer
weniger düngen das heißt wenn sie kleine
kinder haben dann braucht das kind 100
prozent des tagesbedarfs bei uns ist es
immer dass wir nur noch 80 prozent des
bedarf der pflanzen düngen können und
erst jetzt mit drei dinge vor ort und
das soll jetzt nochmals verschärft
werden und aufgrund dessen ist ja wohl
logisch eine pflanze braucht genau wie
ein mensch eine bedarfsgerechte die rede
von überlegungen wir reden von einer
bedarfsgerechten düngung und das ist das
ergebnis davon wir haben noch nie
einstellige werte im protein gab sie
müssen also gewissen also ein guter
bäcker kriegs mit zehn prozent hinzu
gehört auch das hängt von der sorte ab
und es gehört auch zur wahrheit dass wir
von der industrie gezwungen wurden so
hohe qualität so wenig geld als
marktplatz sage für bürgerinnen die mich
die nicht so bewandert ist die
landwirtschaft das prozent fließt also
beim bäcker auf dem backblech und ist
ungenießbar genauso ist es na klar und
wir haben dies ja ich hab einen großen
mühlen gesprochen die haben gesagt wir
waren dieses jahr zum ersten mal in der
historie nicht in der lage dass wir uns
selbst autark mit brot backt gegenwart
zu versorgen konnten die mussten also
dazu kaufen also erweitern kann jetzt
aus den usa wo der bürgerschaft
erreichen wäre könnten wir in
deutschland uns ernähren mit dem was was
da ist verständlich ist wenn es richtig
gebracht verständnis die menge ist da
und die qualität stimmt in diesem jahr
nicht genau absehen weil sie ja die
botschaft den augen noch verrückter
kommt aber jetzt und das ist ein ding
das ich unbedingt loswerden muss wir
haben jetzt sensible gebiet nach brüssel
melden müssen die sensible gebiete heißt
zum beispiel dass sie dort nationalparks
frankreich das gemacht die haben
nationalparks gemeldet die großen und
dort dürfen sie keine
pflanzenschutzmittel mehr einsetzen also
hat sie mir würde sagen pestizide und
wir schützen damit die pflanzen ist wie
medikament also ist es total irre dass
sie das nicht mehr einsetzen können
übrigens gilt das auch für biobauern in
diesen bereichen da der biobauern nutzt
natürlich auch schwefel und kupfer
gerade im weinbau und
nachlässig geht gar nicht ohne und wir
haben wirklich alle schutzgebiete selbst
landschaftsschutzgebiet meldet das heißt
also 60 prozent der fläche deutschlands
wäre damit betroffen das würde also
heißen dass auf diesen flächen keine
landwirtschaft mehr möglich wäre und nur
mit einer geringeren ertrag na also mit
höherem aufwand bleiben geringeren
ertrag also wenn sie umstellen auf bio
na dann ersten sie maximal die hälfte
aber ich sage dir gerade selbst der
biobauer darf seine mittel die er auch
einsetzt das ist ganz klar auch nicht
mehr einsetzen das heißt also dort da
haben wir erträge wie im mittelalter
gar nicht direkt mit herrn özdemir reden
die regierung
ja natürlich müssen wir reden aber wir
haben gehört dass ist eine eine eine
geschichte dieser 2012 angewachsen ist
das ist jetzt neu mit den schutz mit den
sensiblen gebieten das ist neu da geht
es ja auch nicht um je nach anbieter zum
beispiel das ist ja das war ja noch
verrückter mit dem up wiedergeben nein
das ist zu spezifisch hier geht es jetzt
wirklich nur um pflanzenschutzmittel
dass ich denen merkel ist weg ja auch
korrigiert dänemark war aber dünner
genau die haben zehn jahre das gemacht
haben menschen das funktioniert alles
hinten vor nicht wir korrigieren dass
und wie ich sehe immer so wir machen ja
immer das gleiche wo andere schon fehler
gemacht haben oder wenn wir regen aus
brüssel kriegen setzen wir immer noch
einen oben drauf apropos politik
vielleicht noch eine antwort auf ihre
frage ob die landwirtschaftlichen
durchqueren natürlich wären wir das wir
haben ja gleichzeitig finanziell
gefördert durch die eu was weiß ich wie
viele hunderttausend hektar oder
quadratkilometer brachfläche und lauert
dafür bezahlt werden dass sie etwas
brach liegen lassen die vielleicht etwas
anzubauen das ist genau der punkt es ist
ein wahnsinn also jetzt wird uns gesagt
auch wir haben mehr beifall kam für uns
in niedersachsen gehören also auch von
allem möglichen parteien dass ihr kriegt
ja dafür ein ausgleich wir wollen kein
ausgleich wir wollen auch unser unsere
kulturlandschaft die landwirte
erschaffen haben und nicht zur steppe
verkommen lassen das ist doch wahnsinn
und wie willst du das denn allen ernstes
irgendwo auf der welt erklären dass
deutschland sonderweg geht und alles
kauft weise geld haben wie können wir
das moralisch mit ihren christlichen
glauben vertreten ich kann das nicht und
ich werde es auch nicht machen frage was
muss denn hier die fdp tun
die muss ich diesen problemen annehmen
und muss muss dafür sorgen dass viele
verbote und hindernisse einfach
aufgehoben werden und es muss einfach
auch neu
untersucht werden die die zahlen müssen
neu aufgestellt werden wenn sie sagen
das ist wir haben die wir haben
sozusagen die höchstzahlen genommen dann
muss die fdp jetzt
voran faschings wehrte sich erreicht
müsste die koalition platzen lassen na
das war ja mal was sie hatten ja in
akkon war das würde ich jetzt
arena konrad ist die agrarpolitische
schweren im bundestag die die sieht das
genauso ich frage mich auch nur warum
die fdp sich die pd spd-mann zusammentut
und da mal ganz klar schaut hier geht es
ja auch um unsere unserem sozialen
frieden und bezahlbare lebensmittel wie
verknappen wir die wahl wir müssen wir
vielleicht wirklich mal die die die
ampel in schutz nehmen die sind ja noch
nicht so viele monate am werk haben
keine zeit er ist ein jahr wie man
probleme natürlich wie nie und wir haben
gerade ein kompromiss erreicht um jetzt
eben in dieser situation wir uns
befinden wo es eine verknappung auf dem
weltmarkt gibt eben auch zu ermöglichen
dass mehr weizen produziert wird dass
die fruchtfolgen verändert werden also
für die leute heraus dass man zweimal
hintereinander selbe sehen darf man
normalerweise eben nicht mehr also dass
all diese dinge hätte ist die situation
sich auch entspannend also sie können ja
nicht so behaupten dass überhaupt nichts
passieren würde des pro jahr ist er sehe
wenn ich mit den bauern im wahlkreis
rede ich habe letzte woche auch wieder
mehrere besucht wir haben aus ddr zeiten
halt diese ehemaligen lpg ist und recht
große betriebe bei uns die eben eher
sagen naja wir möchten gerne bessere
haltungsform der verbraucher möchte dass
auch wir haben eben nur probleme unsere
stelle dem ich zu kriegen und sogar alle
unsere und sprechende haben etliche
standorte als ich er sage wirklich da
müssen wir entbürokratisieren dass die
bauern wirklich vernünftige einheiten
haben wo die angeblichen richtige
haltung so habe ich es geht alles so
langsam mal wir haben eine bundeskanzler
mit richtlinienkompetenz das problem ist
aber der leider halt nicht so deutlich
dass inter kommt dann eingedeckt ihr
halt und als ein ganz wichtiger punkt
ist diese woche hat jack lemmon stören
das ist ein anderes thema die hörner es
hat ganz klar gesagt wir werden das
einfachste tierwohl tw nicht mehr
bezahlen wir reden hier von sechs cent
auf für ein kilo schweinefleisch weil
das an der ladentheke nicht mehr gekauft
wird und wir wissen es alle am regal
endet die moral und deswegen können wir
so viel stelle umbauen wie wir wollen
der bürger hat gerade andere probleme
draußen der wirkt sich ein regal tiefer
und kauft das günstige wenn wir jetzt
hier in vorleistung treten sollen
welcher betrieb würden das machen
welcher selbstständige würde sagen ich
trete diese vorleistung investieren
anstatt für 200 jahre ohne gewissheit
das klappt kann menschen sie müssen vor
allem die planungsleistungen haben dass
er daneben auch in 20 jahren ihren
return on invest da noch haben genau wer
gibt mir denn aber nehmen wir einmal ein
lösungsweg wenn jetzt sie heute kanzler
sind hell ja welche drei punkte sagen
sie die wissen sofort umgesetzt werden
und das hilft ihre lösung unsere lösung
ist ganz klar dass wir und ich hab's ja
gerade gesagt was ist unser handfesseln
lösen dass wir einfach auch mal
vertrauen jeder landwirt jede landwirten
da draußen ist staatlich ausgebildet
also das kann ja nicht so schlecht sein
na ja und wie sache wir haben die beste
ausgebildete landwirte der welt die
machen keinen schuh natürlich muss man
überall regeln machen dass er vollkommen
klar aber eine erste punkteabbau raster
punkt bürokratieabbau sowie in jedem
handwerk bürokratieabbau die landwirte
machen lassen dass wir natürlich auch
immer besser werden können 24 jahren
aber es gibt doch folgendes wenn wir die
landwirtschaft nicht mehr machen macht
ein anderer viel schlechter was ist dann
fürs klima gewonnen was es für
artenschutz was für tierwohl gewonnen
gar nicht 2.782 weiter vom zweiter punkt
ist ganz wichtig dass wir dieses
oligopol im lebensmitteleinzelhandel
diese riesen mächtigen die über 90
prozent marktanteil haben die
entscheiden nämlich was am regal landet
die bedienen sich auf der ganzen welt
kaufen das billigste ein unter der
einzige standard für lebensmittel die in
die eu kommt ist dass du nicht
gesundheitsgefährdend dahin dürfen da
steht nicht mit tierwohl mit sozialen
standard gar nichts also da wünschen sie
sich mehr stand klar also dann mehr
regeln in dem fall die klar also wir
kämpfen doch mit völlig verzerrten
wettbewerb wie soll denn ein obstbauer
hier bei uns allen ernstes mit dem
marokkaner mithalten wie soll das denn
bitteschön gehen mit den hohen standards
mit mindestlohn das ist doch nicht
machbar das muss auch jedem bürger
draußen klasse etabliert dritter punkt
ist ich hätte noch tausende wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin hin da war jetzt nach
es ja dass wir dass wir einfach
vertrauen von der politik bekommen ich
hab's ja gerade gesagt diese
schutzgebiete die ich die wir gemeldet
haben da hieß es in den 90er jahren dass
die bauern zusammen mit der politik
einen vertrag eingehen dass in den
schutzgebieten
weiterhin landwirtschaft betrieben
werden kann das ist jetzt mit füßen
getreten worden das ist eine faktische
enteignung die auf diesen betrieben auf
diesen flächen darf keine landwirtschaft
mehr schatz den ich möchte mal wissen
wie das ist wenn tatsächlich vw also
gesagt wird ab morgen ist feierabend wir
müssen das hinnehmen sie darf aber sie
lohnt sich vielleicht nicht mehr in das
quatsch das ist das ist nicht mehr
möglich das ist ungefähr das ist vw sage
ich jetzt ein dynamo oder eben da muss
ein fahrrad sitzen damit dass solarstrom
das funktioniert nur vornehmlich glauben
sie mir das ist wirklich wahr lösungs
kleines daran ich bin davon überzeugt
dass johannes eidt sich das sehr genau
anschauen wird weil du trittst ja immer
mitbürger den dialog das muss man ja
sagen auch in seinem eigenen wahlkreis
vielen dank für lösungsplan